it shows them not really my first name
but they call me max yellow
got it mack i thought we hadn't let them
know that for the records
maybe you want to spell it mac make sure
if you spell it on
or spell it on camera make sure you play
mhck you got it
all right max sheldon mack uh where'd
you where'd you grow up originally
where are you from right here in oakland
california from local across the bridge
yeah and uh tell me about your child
they did both your parents as a kid
uh yeah i did i did i have a chinese
mamas
awesome momma i got a dad that was
awesome too good childhood good
childhood i can't complain
no abuse no crazy traumatics no no no no
so did you have role models as a kid
growing up showing you the game yeah
players was my role models
you know uh pimps and players was my
role models i didn't really take to the
gangster thing
i want to be a player i wanted to be a
pimp and growing up in oakland you had
plenty of those
yeah even though i had a good moment a
good daddy
i chose to be in the game
and where what day did you start i
started like 18
i waited till i was 18. how did you how
did you get how did you get your first
girl
i just in my mind just my mind just was
like
get your girl turn around and um
i just called chick at the club and then
when like i was a girl like i was her
boyfriend
and then eventually that she just you
know she eventually she knew that she
knew what she had to do
you know i raced a ride through the
whole show
put her in the car talk to my peer
friends
and um and then bam it just happened you
got you got advice from uh from other
pimps i did i did i got a little advice
but
but you're gonna learn from your first
hold on your first hold i say you're
gonna learn the game
what kind of stuff is she teaching i'll
see just come back in every night and
tell you what pm said to her what tricks
did to her what
tricks wanted stuff like that
and she would bring you how much of her
money all of it every time
i got to have every dime and what did
she get out of it
you know i mean she just getting mean
i'd look out for her
and now she needs something to eat she
need clothes we'd go out sometime we
might let her off we'll go to a concert
or something
so it's like you're you're her boyfriend
yeah
how many girls did you have i didn't
think about about it one time about fall
about four deep at one time
you ever done any prison time yeah i did
some present time before
because eventually eventually i started
selling drugs
i always i went to the other narcotics
yeah drugs are part of the uh the
pimping game
no no no not really when you pimp when
you
just really want to just pimp you know
and then after i got through pimping
then i
i kind of got in the drug gang but how
long were you a pimp
i lost many years many years i've been
for a living
i went from coast to coast like butter
on toast kick states and ass
participants
so you started at 18 i was 18. i'm
61 now 61 now yeah but i bought out the
game i didn't buy that gracefully a long
time ago though
see i always just people call me a pimp
i said no i'm not appearing
to have hoes max had what they want to
have that's why they call me max sheldon
so you're a mac i'm a man what's the
difference between a mac and a pimp
pimps have hoes and max had what they
want to add no but
but uh technically what's what's the
difference i mean that's my philosophy
yeah pimp is a more a stylish suave and
debonair
version of a pimp right i don't know i
think a mac is i think i don't know i
mean mac is a
yeah yeah he is more uh i think you got
to beat them
before you become a mac
right so can uh
can eventually build himself up to the
max status yeah i think you got to beat
it
i mean i i can only speak for me my
philosophy
and i think you got to be the attempt
and then when you graduate to a mac
that's how i look at it like i said i
don't buy that gracefully
pimps have holes max everything wanna
have so i had right now
but i want to have so when you were
rolling what kind of cars were you
driving with i had cadillac's
binges like right now i got two jaguars
i just bought a bmw
what are the personality traits that's
most useful in terms of
being a pimp for you uh
just being smooth suave
dressing
uh so are you married no i'm not married
were you married ever i got married once
before a long time
ago i had a daughter
yeah i'm not a man and how how does a
married life and
temping both uh
it don't exist don't don't go together
to me
i think if you're going to pimp you just
need to just straight lace pimp
what's more important do you love our
money money
money i mean i like love too though
right now right now
or see i'm so much older now so i'm a
little different now
you know back in the day it was like
pimping or i thought i was going to pee
idea
your girls white black hispanic i hate
both kinds i hate white i hate black
you have sex with girls of course
how do you handle a girl when she gets a
little too uh when she gets out of line
you know i try to uh i try not to put
put my hands on them i mean back in the
day i probably did
not too much though i tried to whoop
them by letting that whole show with
them i
keep on the whole show for hours and
hours and hours
so that reputation that tends to use
intimidation or violence or whatever to
get the girls
some something you know everybody
appeared different you know some pimps
do that some parents don't
you got soft shoe pimps you got gorilla
pimps
you know i try not to put my hands on
them i didn't really like that
so the laws have changed a lot since
back when you were doing it is that why
you got out yeah but but see but she's
you know what cats tell me they went to
jail for pimping and pandering
in my mind you don't go to jail for
pimping you go there for miss pimping
your friend of mine told me that one
time so you don't go to the alpha pimp
and you go
there for miss pepper
is is part of the game having the girls
figure out ways to get money from the
john's oh yeah yeah yeah
it's not simply just sex for money
sometimes no i'm not he got naughty talk
they got to talk for you got to talk for
it they got to perform for it
you got to put on the act they know how
to do it
figure out what guys have money yeah
well
some guys do not steal that's what i'm
saying they know how to fill on your
dick with one hand and be in your pocket
with the other hand
uh huh what's the longest you had a girl
stay with you
about four five years
yeah one of my turnouts maybe longer
than that
what do you think the core of the pimp
and prostitute relationship is is it
that
she's looking for a boyfriend is she
looking for a father figure that she
never had
you know something to me some women are
just born to pay a parent
somehow just born to pay a pound just
want to be a pimp on a be with a pimp
what's the craziest thing you've seen in
all your years of doing oh man that's a
good question it's been so long since i
did it
as far as what like the just the
the thing that makes you shake your head
after is what tricks won't
everybody but they come on tell me what
a trick won't yeah that's crazy
oh man crazy i've heard it all i think
yeah yeah me too they want to
dig beat they want to be [ __ ] on they
want to be pissed on
they want to do some sick stuff man i
guess that's why they call them tricks
and these are
guys with money that have yeah these
guys with big money yeah yeah
and don't want their wives to know what
their fetish is
how has the game changed since you oh
man the game didn't change these
youngsters they
they they to me they took the art out of
pivot
you know i mean just like i'm just like
now you can look across if you look
what's like across the street you see
how the penis dress now
you see back in the day you should be
able to tell a pin from a drug dealer
or pen from a gangster see a player
gonna dress like
me you know but nowadays the youngsters
is
they ain't accepting no news if you
knock a hole
you say if somebody if if i knock
somebody for they hoe
and then i call myself servant and
renewed they don't want to accept the
news his rules and regulations depicted
back then i don't know by now these
youngsters they'd be like i ain't
accepting no news that's my whole
but i knocked the fan square
you know so yeah they took the art out
of paper to me
yeah what are you proudest of in your
life what am i what what are you
proudest of
in your life where am i proud what are
you proud of
oh you know i just believe like right
now just keep it real
play fair treat people i want to be
treated
you know all right
that's about it man you know i never
spoke on camera like kids before so it's
kind of
he's got all right it's okay you did a
great job
all right max sheldon well thank you so
much for talking with me all right
good luck with wherever you go from here
all right i'm going straight up to the
top
thanks man bye mom
you